this is John nce and uh this is the soda
pop this is skelo soda pop stop right
now we have about 700 different kinds of
sodas we have 700 different kinds of
beers we have everything you can't find
and some things you'll just look at and
say I didn't even know they were made
this is actually a cucumber soda and
this this one started here and it became
soda of the year in 2010 it's wonderful
this one right here
it's a it's an
oon and it's an it's a liquorish
flavored soda I didn't I don't like
liquorish and I tasted I went oh my
goodness uh we were an Italian grocery
store and the neighborhood was changing
and then at about that same time the um
Supermarket chains bought the
distribution channel for the little
markets and closed them down we were
being put out of business and it wasn't
nice the way they were doing it and I
started thinking about it and I said you
know what you should be happy that Pepsi
Cola doesn't own your shell space and
you can sell anything you want so I went
out and 12 found 25 little brands of
soda put them on the shelf and what you
find out is that other little people in
business they're still out there you're
in glass bottles you're using real
ingredients you're using cane sugar I
mean what more can people ask for you
said uh cane sugar in there oh oh you
want to know about the United States and
our syrup beware I mean you want to go
to the supermarket you can pick up
frozen foods you can pick up candy it
doesn't matter what it is you can pick
up a loaf of bread and it'll have corn
syrup in it where didn't have it in
there 25 years ago everything you do has
corn syrup in it why this was the first
soda put in a bottle it was actually
sold as a as a tonic just to to calm
your stomach if you try to drink it like
most people drink a soda today you're
going to get carbonated cough medicine
but if you sip it you may get a Cola
Root Beer cinnamon vanilla licorice
black cherry flavor you might get one
you might get four five different
flavors these come from the Republic of
Georgia this is actually made from
naturally carbonated water they don't
use a machine it bubbles out of the
ground that way when I graduated from
college and I decided I wanted to go in
the grocery business and and my father
said you're going to go to work for a
big company I said no pop I want to come
in here because every day is different
he just shook his head he says you know
you're going to make a living that's all
you're going to make and you're a damn
fool go to work for the big company and
get paid to do it and I just I don't
want to do
that that was important I mean it's
important you got to be happy with what
you do if you're not happy with what you
do we're doing it all for the wrong
reason thank you very much to John nce
and the staff at the soda pop stop they
are on York bouevard and Highland Park
Los Angeles and a link to their site is
in the description
and my apologies for the dodgy camera
work it was just being my GoPro but
there was no way I was going to pass up
a visit to something as wonderful and
offbeat as this